women oftentimes complain about you know
men oh men sleep around they well you
know what they sleep around with someone
right so the way that you stop that
behavior is that you stop putting out so
easily you you command respect and as a
result men will have to change the way
they behave but that's why i believe
that majority of the consequences that
we see today are due to feminism
i believe that women weren't playing
fair and then men just said okay
whatever you got 30 of men that are not
sleeping with anyone and you know
they're they're in a situation now where
they're like what the the thing about
that because when i say that a lot of
people assume that that's just a problem
for men
not really understanding that that's 30
of me like a family is a man's
a family is what holds a man to society
a man has no reason to care about
anything that goes on in society unless
he has a family because men just tend to
be more independent so if you want a man
to
like care about society give him a
family give him a reason to get up and
be productive or you won't